how can we create life in the lab from
scratch
what have been the most promising
attempts at creating life in the lab
from scratch has anyone actually been
able to do it do you think anyone will
be able to do it in the near future if
they haven't already
um can yeah i think that um nobody has
made life in the lab from scratch lots
of people would argue that they have
made progress the craig ventner i think
the synthesis of a synthetic genome
milestone in human uh achievement
brilliant yeah can we just walk back and
say
what
uh
would you say from your perspective one
of the world experts in exactly this
area
what does it mean to create life from
scratch where if you sit back whether
you do it or somebody else does it it's
like
damn
this is we just created life
um well what i would i can tell you what
i would expect i would like to be able
to do
is to
go from sand to cells in my lab
and
and can you explain what sand is yeah
just
just in organic stuff like like like
basically just so sand it's just silica
silicon oxide with some other ions in it
maybe some inorganic carbon some
carbonates
just basically clearly dead stuff you
you could just grind rocks into sand and
it would be what in like in a vacuum so
they could remove anything else that
could possibly
uh
be uh
like a shadow of life that can assist in
the chemical you could do that you could
insist and say look i'm gonna take and
not just inorganic i want some more i
want to cheat and have some organic but
i want inorganic organic and i'll
explain the play on words in a moment so
i would like to basically put into a
world let's say a completely you know a
synthetic world if you like a closed
world
put some inorganic materials and just
literally add some energy in some form
be it lightning or heat
uv light
and run this thing in cycles
over time and let it solve the search
problem so i see the origin of life as a
search problem in chemical space
and then i would wait literally wait for
a life form to crawl out the test tube
that's the joke i tell my group
literally wait uh uh for a very and
don't worry it's gonna be very feeble
it's not gonna take over the world you
know there's ways of ethically
containing his last words
it was indeed indeed indeed but i i i
you know this is being recorded right
it'll make you
it will not make you look good once it
crawls out of the lab and destroys all
of human civilization but yes but there
is very good there's a very good things
you can do to prevent that yeah for
instance if you put stuff in your world
which isn't earth abundant so let's say
we make life based on molybdenum
and it escapes it would die immediately
because there's not enough molybdenum in
the environment so we can put in we can
we can do it we can do responsible life
or as i fantasize with my research group
on our away day that would go in it's
you know i think it's actually
morally
we if light if we don't find if you met
until humanity finds life in the
universe this is going on a tangent it's
our moral obligation to make origin of
life bombs identify dead planets and
bomb them with our origin of life
machines and make them alive i think it
is our moral obligation to do that um
i'm sure some people might argue with me
about that but i think that we need a
lot more life in the universe and then
we kind of forget would we did it and
then come back
and say where did you come from but
coming back to the what i'd expect so
i'll just say
are you back it's i think this is once
again a rick and morty episode
definitely it's definitely all rick and
morty all the way down so we i imagine
we have this pristine
um experiment and everything is you know
sanitized and we put in inorganic
materials and we we have cycles with
them day night cycles up down whatever
and we
look for evidence of replication and
evolution over time and that's what the
experiment should be now are there
people doing this in the world right now
there are a couple of there's some
really good groups doing this there's
some really interesting scientists doing
this around the world
they're kind of
perhaps
too much associated with the scam
so and
and so they're using molecules that are
already were already invented by biology
so there's a bit of replication built in
um but i still think the work that is
doing they're doing is amazing
but i would like people to be a bit
freer and say let's just basically shake
a load of sand in a box and wait for
life to come out because that's what
happened on earth and so that we have to
understand that now how would i know
i've been successful
well because i'm not obsessing with
what molecules are in life now
i i would wager a vast quantity of money
um i'm not very rich so just be a few
dollars but for me
um the the
the solution space will be different
so the the genetic material will be not
rna
the proteins will not be what we think
they'll it would the solutions will be
just completely different and it might
be and it'll be very feeble because
that's the other thing we should be able
to show
um fairly robustly that even if i did
make or someone did make a new life form
in the lab it would be so poor
that it's not going to leap out it is
the the fear about making a lethal life
form
in the lab from scratch is um
similar to us imagining that we're going
to make the terminator uh boston
dynamics tomorrow yeah simply not you
and and i and the problem is we don't
communicate that properly i know you you
yourself very um you explain this very
well you know there is not the ai
catastrophe coming
um we're very far away from that that
doesn't mean we should ignore it same
with the origin of life catastrophe it's
not coming anytime soon we shouldn't
ignore it but we shouldn't let that fear
stop us from doing those experiments but
this is a much much longer discussion
because there's a lot of details there i
would say there's potentials for
catastrophic events
to happen
in much dumber ways within in ai space
there's a lot of ways to create like uh
social networks that are creating a kind
of uh accelerated
set of events that we might not be able
to control the
social network virality in the digital
space
can create
mass movements of ideas that can then if
times are tough
create military conflict and all those
kinds of things but that's not intel
super intelligent ai
that's an interesting
at scale application of ai if you look
at viruses viruses are pretty dumb
but at scale their application is pretty
detrimental and so origin of life much
like
all the kind of virology you know
um
the very contentious word of gain of
function research and virology sort of
like research on viruses uh
messing with them genetically
that can create a lot of problems if not
done well so we have to be very
cautious so there's a kind of whenever
you're ultra cautious about stuff in ai
or in virology and biology
it borders on cynicism i would say where
it's like everything we do is going to
turn out to be destructive and terrible
so i'm just going to sit here and do
nothing
okay that's a possible solution
except for the fact that somebody's
going to do it
it's science and technology progresses
so we have to do it in an ethical way in
a good way considering in a transparent
way in an open way
uh
considering
um
all the possible positive trajectories
that could be taken and making sure as
much as possible that we walk those
trajectories so yeah i don't think
terminator is coming
but
a totally unexpected version of
terminator maybe around the corner yeah
it might be here already yeah so i agree
with that and so going back to the
origin of life discussion i think that
in synthetic biology right now
we have to be very careful about how we
edit genomes and edit synthetic biology
to do things so that's kind of that's
where things might go wrong in the same
way as you know twitter turning
ourselves into kind of
strange scale effects
i would love origin of life research or
artificial life research to get to the
point where we have those worries
because that's why i think we're just so
far away from that we are ju you know
right now i think there are two really
important um angles there is the
origin of life people researchers who
are faithfully working on this
and trying to make those molecules the
scan molecules i talk about
and then there are people on the
creationist side who's saying look the
fact you can't make these molecules and
you can't make a cell means that um
evolution isn't true and all this other
stuff gotcha yeah and so and and i find
that really frustrating because actually
the origin of life researchers are all
working in good faith right yes and and
so what i'm trying to do is give origin
of life research a little bit more of a
of a of an open
an open context and one of the things i
think is important um i really want to
make a new life form in my lifetime i
really want to prove that life
is a general phenomena a bit like
gravity in the universe
because i think that's going to be
really important for humanity's
global psychological state
meaning going forward that's beautifully
that's beautifully put so one it will
help us understand ourselves
so that's useful for science but two it
gives us
a kind of hope if not
an awe
at all the huge amounts
of alien civilizations that are out
there if you can build life
and understand just how easy it is to
build life
then that's just as good if not much
better than discovering life on another
planet yeah it's
i mean it's cheaper it's much cheaper
and much easier
and uh
probably much more conclusive because
once you're able to create life
like you said it's a search problem
that uh
there's probably a lot of different ways
to do it so once you create the
once you find the first solution you
probably have all the right methodology
for finding all kinds of other solutions
you